autocracy is a bad thing whether it's
practice one-on-one in the playground or
whether it's practiced by government and
that's why I started to say well I'd
like Liberty I like individualism like
to be left alone I like to kind of do it
I want to do and if that's the way you
think and big government and left is not
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special I am super excited
to welcome to the show the great one
Mark Levin author of the brand new book
on freedom of the press we're gonna get
to all of our questions mark levin in
just one second but first some topics in
life are uncomfortable to talk about sex
is one of those things but sex is also
one of the most important things in life
especially within the context of
marriage
studies show that 70% of dudes who
experience erectile dysfunction don't
get treated for it for just that reason
it can be awkward to discuss but
sometimes things just don't work the way
they are supposed to it's a medical
problem and something to get solved not
something to be ashamed of that's where
our friends at Roman come in thankfully
Roman has created an easy way to get
checked out by a doctor and get treated
for IDI online with Roman you can get
medical care for eg if appropriate from
the comfort and privacy of your own home
you can handle everything online in a
convenient discreet manner getting
started is really simple just go to get
Roman comm slash pen complete an online
visit if your doctor decides treatment
would be appropriate they can prescribe
genuine medication that can be delivered
in discreet packaging direct your door
with free two-day shipping dudes go talk
to the doctor erectile dysfunction can
be really tough to tackle it's really
important to get it checked out with
Roman it's easy to connect with the
doctor just go to get Roman comm slash
pen get a free online visit and free
two-day shipping that is get Roman comm
slash pen for a free visit to get
started g-e-t our oma ENCOM slash man
get Roman comm slash Bend go check it
out right now well mark thanks so much
for stopping by it's a great on a great
pleasure so we have a new book out on
freedom of the press where we talk about
really the history of the press and
obviously this has become hot topic
probably hot topic number one in the
country given president Trump's use of
the phrase fake and it's so often so
let's talk a little bit about where we
are with the press
so obviously you look at the polls
people hate the press they don't trust
the press aside from the obvious which
is that the press is left-wing why do
you think that that trust was undermined
because 20 years ago people did trust
the press and the press was similarly
left-wing you get a lot more competition
in the press today we've got the
internet you've got your show you've got
my show you've got other platforms that
are out there a citizen go on the
internet and get news from anywhere in
the world
different bloggers they may follow
different sites they may follow and then
they're watching CNN or they're watching
MSNBC
not particularly bright people
just pounding away pounding away the
same thing every day and from one
perspective there's no diversity in the
newsroom there's no diversity on these
stations and also they combine news with
opinion you cannot tell who the news
host is for the most part on CNN or
MSNBC the same blurring is occurring at
the New York Times in the Washington
Post between their news and editorial
pages and it's particularly crystallized
now because they so hate Trump they
can't control themselves and and they'll
tell you they hate Trump and they can't
control themselves and in many ways it's
become very political that is they play
like to the Democrat Party base that's
where they play for their ratings and
they're not getting any that's where
they play for their hits and it's not
that it just happened now this has been
building this is an ideology that's also
taught in many of the journalism schools
most of the journalists studied you can
go to journalism school lot of them come
out of the Democrat Party or Democratic
ministration some Republicans but mostly
the other and so they come with an
ideological point of view and there's
this whole new movement called social
activism journalism they call public
journalism community journalism but it
is what it is and they're pushing the
progressive agenda and they say a lot of
these guys let's stop hiding this you
know but for us there wouldn't have been
a civil rights movement well actually
it'll was but for them but for us you
know women wouldn't have voted well
actually they would have and but for us
there wouldn't be Obamacare so we should
proudly say who we are and interpret the
news and analyze the news and give it to
the public who are number one too stupid
they think we're too busy to understand
it anyway
so this whole notion of objective truth
seeking for the most part is dying on
the vine do you think that it was better
when people called themselves objective
truth seekers like there's sort of this
weird bifurcation and conservative
thought about what the media should be
there are some of us I'm on the side
that says don't even bother to pretend
you're objective just give me who you
are I'd rather listen to your show or my
show or even pod save America where they
say okay here's who we our democratic
staffers and this is what we think about
the issues then have to hear from Chris
Cuomo or Don Lemon pretending that they
represent some sort of higher objective
truth and then there are folks who say
well you know the problem there is the
conflation what we do need
is journalists are going to get back to
objective journalism what do you think
is the solution here is it going back to
sort of the founding era partisan
newspapers or is it the pursuit of
actual objective journalism and this is
the core of it it's a great point I
think they're fighting among themselves
in their newsrooms a lot do we come out
of the closet fully and say who we are
or do we continue to pretend that were
nonpartisan and objective and about a
hundred years ago the rise of the
progressive movement also infected the
so-called press we had the party press
where they were very transparent you had
papers like the Arkansas
democrat-gazette in the Arizona
Republican now the Arizona Republic they
aligned with political parties and
candidates and ideologies really
starting about 1780
moving into the beginning of the Civil
War and then the beginning of the last
century you had this progressive
movement and they were not going to
leave the press alone John Dewey and
others and so they decided we won't
decide really what the news is we of the
the masterminds and so forth same people
going to run the government run the
economy we're gonna run the media too
and the walter Lippmann is very
outspoken about this he was iconic at
the time reporter and he said so we're
going to apply a scientific approach a
knowledge approach to all of this we'll
gather the information then we'll
determine what the public needs to know
we'll use her intelligence to tell the
very busy public what the news is so
this has been going on for about a
century but the difference today is this
fight that's going on on the Left which
really has pretty much monopoly control
of news as a as an aggregate and it's
whether or not to be very blunt about it
or not and I think you can see that
playing out on television - and this
this commingling of news and opinion you
can see that playing out on television -
the answer is technology
the answer is progressive creativity not
ideology progressive creativity because
what is technology technology is this
technology is the brain technology is is
people trying to figure out how to do
things differently how to do things
better to improve upon what is and you
can see some of that now on the Internet
these new platforms and I was George
Gilder who I
on my Fox show not that long ago he said
these current platforms which in many
ways are anti speech Facebook Google
whatever you want to call he said
they're gonna go by the wayside because
the Israelis and the Japanese are
working on new platforms and this is why
I have a problem sometimes when people
say technology puts Americans out of
work technology is is is a threat to
America no technology is America because
the freer the country the more
technology the more creativity the more
productivity so we develop our ways out
of these things we think our ways are
these things I make a distinction
between the modern mass media any free
press the modern mass media is not
upholding a free press there's nothing
doing the free press other than
government not interfering
it's killing a free press and that's why
it celebrates certain people who really
nobody's like aoc one of your favorites
or or Talib or Omar these are really
detestable people but the media play
them up the media defend them and so
forth versus others who they either
ignore or they or they try to destroy
that's not free speech so I think free
speech is in good shape as long as we
have technology development and no
government interference I think the mass
media is in deep trouble
the New York Times would probably be out
of business today but for a billionaire
out of Mexico a telecommunications
magnate about about 20% of it Washington
Post would be dead but for Beezus buying
it
CNN's ratings are in the tank just a
matter of time and MSNBC doesn't have a
business plan after trouble ease when
you talk about the contrast between the
the media outlets and a free press Amin
you can certainly see that playing out
even with the blaze TV where you do some
work you know the fact is that you know
over the past few weeks we've seen as
voxcom openly I mean they they issued a
letter the editors issued a letter to
YouTube asking for them to rewrite their
rules to ban steven crowder a comedian
because one of their journalists was
offended by jokes that Crowder was
making it's amazing to watch pseudo
journalistic outlets that are basically
activist outlets calling for the
silencing of of an enormous number of
voices on the other side and they don't
just do it by going
the big tech companies and telling them
to silence they don't just go to
Facebook or YouTube
they also astroturf boycotts again shows
like yours the astroturf boycotts
against shows like mine they go after
advertisers they do this routine where
Huffington Post reporter will call up
one of your advertisers and then say do
you agree with what Mark Levin just said
on X well what does it matter with the
advertiser thinks the advertiser advert
has done lots of stuff but they're
creating this this pseudo journalistic
patina around an activists core and I
think that's what's what's driving
people up a wall the greatest threat to
free speech is this phony journalism
what is freedom of the press it's an
extension of freedom of speech and
really freedom of the press is sort of a
community aggregate people communicating
with each other I mean they're only
press pushing for revolution pushing
America's principles having debates
having discussions all that sort of
thing the left has no tolerance for
diversity of viewpoints has no tolerance
for independent thinking it believes in
conformity and uniformity and so they're
attacking these platforms and these
platforms are buckling if they don't
believe them themselves and promote that
agenda YouTube is gonna die if it
follows vox youtube will marginalize
itself YouTube will be viewed as just
another left-wing creation another the
left-wing enterprise and half the
country will leave it 80% of Republicans
right now distrust the media 80% of
Democrats like the media that's why I
call it the Democratic Party media
that's what they are that's what they
want to be if YouTube wants to be an
appendage to a crackpot left-wing
vicious individual and website fine I'll
give you an example
I was absolutely flirting with the idea
of putting my radio show on YouTube now
I won't do it I want nothing to do with
YouTube the way that they've treated
steven crowder and please don't tell me
you don't like what crowder says or the
things he says I mean the left is
embracing anti-semites the left is
embracing all kinds of Kooks you have
comedians out there who set a hell of a
lot worse and crowler ever said 20 30 40
years ago of comedians who can't even go
on college campuses anymore because of
the speech codes and all the rest that's
going on
we support free speech we support
freedom of the press we support
competition because we think the
American people are smart they'll
discern one or the other what they like
or what they don't like well what do you
think ought to be done with some of
these social media companies there's a
really interesting and sort of rich
debate now happening inside the
conservative movement about Facebook and
YouTube and Twitter particularly a lot
of folks saying these are monopolies and
they ought to be broken up some people
suggesting that the government ought to
come in and regulate them I've made the
argument in the past that either they're
a platform or than a publisher that they
don't get to act like voxcom and then be
treated as though they're in a TNC phone
line you know do you think that the
government has any role here or will the
free market should we just let the free
market take its course which is an
argument certainly open to I think the
free market should take its course but
it's not the government protects these
sites so the government ought to remove
the protection and now they're really in
the free market let's see how they
handle themselves whether it's
litigation whether it's public opinion
whatever it is you two won't survive
doing what it's doing it's not going to
survive doing what it's doing it ought
not be protected in any way I feel the
same way with the press since 1964 the
Sullivan case there you know we had a
free we had a very free robust press
before the Supreme Court jumped in and
when the press even when we had the
First Amendment originally you still had
state libel laws and so forth you could
still be sued under state libel laws so
there's no check whatsoever not on a
free press or an absolute outrageous
comments that's fine so let that system
play out that our legal system play out
I don't think these entities should be
protected by federal law in any respect
let them be out there with the rest of
us and deal with the rest of the issues
and figure out their business model that
way the government is going to step in
and do what exactly who's gonna step in
and do it I get very nervous when
Congress steps and it's filled with
knuckleheads who do not respect the
Constitution you can see them today
you've had a number of administrations
that have wanted to kill talk radio
you've had presidents like Obama that
wanted to kill Fox you've had this
nonsense about net neutrality those are
the people who are now going to manage
and I don't think that's any better the
mark
it works no protections and let them die
or live so in a second I want to ask you
about sort of broader ramifications of
that conversation particularly in the
conservative movement the battle between
the so called nationalist populist and
sort of free-market / libertarian folks
I'm gonna ask about that in just one
second first the fact is going to the
post office a lot of good stuff at the
post office but you know it's not fun
actually being at the post office last
time I was at the post office I got a
$100 ticket let me tell you something
about la you stop outside the post
office for five seconds and you're in
the red zone at all they can't clean up
the homeless problem but they will give
you a traffic ticket like nobody's
business who's got time for all that
traffic parking lugging all your mail
and packages it's a hassle which is why
you need stamps calm one of the most
popular time-saving tools for small
businesses stamps con eliminates trips
to the post office and saves you money
with discounts you can't even get at the
post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office direct
to your computer whether your small
office sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products even a
warehouse if you're sending thousands of
packages a day stamps com can handle all
of it with ease with stamps calm you get
five cents off every first-class stamp
and up to 40% off Priority Mail which is
a heck of a deal not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps calm is a true
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and the digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that stamps comm enter Shapiro I want to
talk a little bit about this some this
division that's broken out inside the
Republican Party it seems like a almost
a tripartite division there's they're
sort of the libertarian contingent
people who say government should be as
small as humanly possible it shouldn't
be involved in nearly any way in
American life social fabric should fill
in the gaps leave everybody to their own
that's the only way we're gonna get
along then there are folks who are sort
of social conservatives who say listen
government was left alone and government
then started cramming down leftism so we
need to retake the means of production
effectively and start promulgating a
virtuous reform econo gender we have to
we have to try and create certain
certain incentives for people to get
married we have to start teaching
certain values from the government side
and that we have to use the tools of
government in order to promulgate
certain messages and then there
are a group of folks who have come about
who really suggests that the government
ought to radically restructure the
market in in pretty major ways they're
afraid of technological development they
believe that the free market has led to
the emptying out of the American family
they're afraid that that market forces
have hyper individualized the country
and that only government regulation can
put all of this back together where do
you come down in this debate where do
you think the role of government lies a
couple of things here that's a great
question that's very complex first of
all the Constitution list when it comes
to the government I'm not a libertarian
when it comes to the government to me
that's a way of life okay if you want to
live that way in many ways I do if you
believe in a free market economy fine
when we're talking about the government
I'm a constitutionalist and what does
the Constitution say basically you're
the powers of the federal government no
more you want to expand them you amend
the Constitution that's where my head is
as a gentleman that's where I start from
as far as libertarianism goes I don't
interpret the Constitution from the
libertarian perspective I interpret what
it says and I try to apply what was
intended at the time there's history or
there's not history and you do the best
job you can but in terms of
libertarianism I'm pretty much a
libertarian when it comes to economic
matters I can be convinced that this
matter that matter depending on what the
situation is but that's where I start
from I am NOT a national populist
because there's not a dimes worth a
difference between national populism of
Bernie Sanders and somebody on the right
because I can't define it neither can
they and matter of fact they like to
quote each other they like to embrace
each other it is an odd thing to say
that I'm a constitutionalist but I'm
also a national populist what does that
mean the framers rejected both
nationalism and populism they created
federalism
moreover they rejected populism because
we don't have a democracy we have a
republic populism scares the hell out of
me here you tell me my neighbors get to
vote if I've unalienable rights my
neighbors get the vote on my property
rights my neighbors get to make
decisions like this or if that's not
what populism is what is populism or
there's certain politicians who get to
tell us what the American people think
and what the American people feel I
don't think so so what I tell my
audience is look at the Declaration of
Independence that's not about populism
it's not about nationalism
it's about Americanism there's a
difference between nationalism and
Americanism Americanism is patriotic
right Americanism is supporting our
culture supporting the principles of the
revolution
I can't even the so-called nationalists
can't really define nationalism and yet
they tell us they're concerned about the
central government and big government
and they're disconnected from the people
well how do they think this is going to
work we're gonna play by sites every
week know those st. people are going to
be making those same decisions in lieu
of us or in lieu of states or in lieu of
towns or in lieu of families or in lieu
of so forth and so on so nationalism
clearly is not the answer
populism is ill-defined that's clearly
not the answer I don't believe in my
biography so we have to do a better job
perhaps of explaining constitutionalism
and capitalism and all these things that
were made of such a magnificent country
any country can be nationalists populous
country but that's not what our
Constitution is that's not what our
founding is so with that said what do
you think that the role of government is
when you talk about the role of
government under the Constitution that
really applies to the federal government
obviously what do you think the role of
government let's say stay and locally
ought to be you're you're constructing
the ideal Mark Levin Society what would
government doing what would government
not do probably a mix of Idaho Utah and
Florida in other words that that is a
great question separate question okay so
what kind of state like this magnificent
State of California's gone to hell you
know shouldn't the resources it has the
geography it has the people that has but
the government is horrendous and you
have one party government I lived here
briefly when the Republicans were in
control which was pretty good as a
matter of fact I think it was Pete
Wilson and then an a fairly Republican
legislature so what is the role of state
government well again I would look at
the Constitution to see what the role of
the government is there as well but it
has a bigger role than the federal
government it's supposed to have a
bigger role in the federal government
roads bridges all this this I'll give
you another issue where I have a more
people are gonna have a problem me I
don't believe in two trillion dollar
infrastructure program
I think that's nuts all that does is
featherbed the states and the localities
and they send it a
big list and all it allows is the
Democrats to put in about eight hundred
billion dollars worth of non-road stuff
and so forth I joke in my community they
wind a road from two to four lanes now
we have more traffic than ever before
because people
oh there's now four lanes you can say oh
yeah so so my attitude is even at the
state level the less government the
better but it depends I mean I want law
enforcement there other things that the
state government does that are important
to me maybe they should be doing more
rather than a federal EPA let's leave it
to the state equivalent of the EPA's
when it comes to States maybe they'll
have more of a say in immigration
particulars there on the border then
they should in Washington DC with a
largely unaffected even benefit from
from open borders and the politics and
that comes with that so I am the belief
that states get it wrong a lot there are
some terrible terrible states places
where I wouldn't want to live but that's
the point isn't it I don't have to live
there in one of the states as a country
and one of the things that's been
happening and it's it's really I think a
problem is the nationalization of the
local so you see this with abortion law
particularly is that I haven't seen a
lot of people from Georgia threatening
not to go to New York because New York
liberalized its abortion lots of the
ultimate extreme and yet I'm seeing
businesses across the country say that
they're not going to do business with
the state of Georgia or with the state
of Alabama because of their abortion law
every local decision now becomes a
national referendum on the issue itself
it's as though federalism I mean I think
that it's probably dying they may be
well dead where do you think we stand in
terms of federalism and if it falls
apart do you think the country can stick
together first of all I think the
Supreme Court is largely nationalized
these social issues and it's very
troubling to me you know for a lot of
people in a lot of communities they
quote-unquote evolved on these issues
you know like the anti sodomy laws that
were just used as an excuse in the 1960s
for the federal government again for the
Federal Supreme Court again in Vaughan a
lot of these cases even though there
were only fourteen states that had them
and they were dying on the vine anyway
but they always want to use some event
to make the case it's like same-sex
marriage there's no constitutional basis
for same-sex marriage I'm sorry
upset people that is a state issue but
over time and you can see it with
Lawrence in other cases they went
through the Anthony Kennedy in
particular they work their way through
they knew they'd be there 2025 years on
the bench and and they decided to to
nationalize that issue and what people
need to understand is there's winners
and losers when that happens and a court
can change and they may nationalize an
issue you don't like and it's just hard
for me to believe that a five-to-four
decision with one justice all the Sun
can determine what a fundamental right
is and what a fundamental right isn't
depending on whether the justice votes
this way or votes that way on the
abortion issue to my viewers that ought
to be absolutely a state issue
everybody knows roe v-- wade is a
judicial joke even Ruth Bader Ginsburg
thinks it's a judicial joke if they want
abortion on demand nationally then try
and get it through an amendment if it is
that popular in every corner of the
country
and if every woman in the country
believes in this then go get your
amendment they don't even try because
they can't abortion is one issue but
there's a whole host of issues that are
being nationalized centralized imposed
on the American people and the problem
with that is you're right it undermines
the whole notion of diversity in this
country one of the things that has kept
this diverse country together people
with different religions and backgrounds
and histories and all the rest is the
fact that you have states that have
different approaches it'd be like the
death penalty if they eliminate the
death penalty all across the country
they may one day that means the death
penalty in states that have aggressively
like Florida and Virginia and I might
add I've homes in both thankfully that
that will change the landscape of these
states and I think to myself why is it
that we don't lead people in these
states alone to make these decisions in
other words is it because they're dumber
is it because that's because they don't
agree with us so we're gonna force our
will and willing them and when it comes
to the Hyde Amendment as an example
which is a question of whether the
federal taxpayer should pay for abortion
we've now reached a point where they're
saying we must pay for the abortions
even if we disagree with them and it's
even gotten worse I think Kamala Harris
has made a proposal where she says like
the Voting Rights Act the federal
government should
look at it in advance and I'm gonna on
this this is tyranny and it's close to
fascism quite frankly so federalism
which allows mobility which allows
diversity is the glue that keeps the
country together ironically enough
centralization uniformity is what tears
us apart and will destroy this country
yeah I also noticed that Kamala Harris
proposal and I thought exactly the same
thing talks about on my show it feels
like what's happened is that all
Authority has now been sucked up to the
federal level and then delegated from
the vestigial organ that is the
legislature over to the executive which
basically runs like a dictatorship
regardless of which party is in charge
it's though the bureaucracy does
everything you know it's interesting
about this meanwhile they're out there
with their sanctuary cities so they
don't always support federal control and
so it really is the end justifies the
means for the left they'll talk about
free speech for Nazis marching in Skokie
and then they'll try and shut down
steven crowder because they don't like
his speech and particular is he's
effective but really are they real do
they really believe in the vote they say
every vote should count they believe
every vote should count when they win
they don't believe every vote should
count what they lose then they turn to
the courts where they turn to the
bureaucracy the unelected parts of the
government to impose their will if the
president united states says you know
what i'm gonna get rid of daca and then
we have a federal judge appointed by
Obama says no that's the law no it's not
the law it was that the Department of
Homeland Security issued that that
ruling or that rule so how was that
thought one president is the law and the
next president can't remove that law you
can see it in the immigration field you
can see it in the environmental field
and so forth so for the left it is
pushing towards their ideology their
utopia which is really hell and if it's
federalism one day great if its central
government one day great if it's
elections one day great if it's a Fiat
by the Supreme Court great whatever it
is it is do you think that the country
is going to hold together because I mean
I'm seeing I talked you know recently
with Bernal Stutzman who owns Arlene's
flowers up in Washington State she's
basically being shut down because as a
religious person living in a liberal
state she's being forced to cater
same-sex weddings or they're going
shut her down and I was talking with a
lawyer and one of the things that I said
is I don't even understand why this is a
freedom of religion case this seems to
me like there should be a basic freedom
of association case meaning why do I
have to serve anybody and of course the
answer is that we have broadened out the
provisions of the Civil Rights Act to
include pretty much everything now so
the government instituted segregation
and then the federal government came in
and said how about this how about we not
only overrule the states on this stuff
we also inject ourselves into private
businesses and then control that
top-down how can the government how can
the country stick together under these
circumstances I think we're all are we
all just gonna end up in areas where we
agree with these more difficult there's
no question about it because you're
attacking one of the strengths of the
country which is you know the left likes
to talk about diversity but they don't
support diversity it is their way of the
highway whether it's cake cases or
whether it is what we've been talking
about and so forth and this is a problem
and I'm not sure how to fix it
and I'm not sure if it can be fixed but
we need to keep talking about it and
keep keep exposing it because more and
more people are gonna feel like they're
not part of society it's also
destructive of the culture what is it
exactly where exactly do they want to
take us I always say you know we have
our Constitution that's our blueprint
what's their blueprint where's their
blueprint when does this end how do we
know that we have utopia when when we
know that we've achieved paradise and
this is one of the things I wrote about
in my book of Mara topia in the first
chapter which is they never are wrong
that is we just haven't tried hard
enough we haven't had enough resources
or people are just too intransigent or
we're the wrong person was running it's
like Obamacare I thought Obamacare was
gonna deliver everything we wanted
nobody even talks about Obamacare
anymore it's now Medicare for all you
know which is a single government
iron-fisted soviet-style health care
from the top down you know Milton
Friedman once said it's one not a
national populace you know he once said
most of the problems we have is with big
government he said we have problems in
our lives and problems that are but the
big problems we have mostly are with
government and I agree with that
and so people who believe there ought to
be more of it I just reject it on a hand
so obviously
from controversial figure not just now
but was in 2016 you voted for him you
supported him you didn't support him in
the primaries obviously supported Cruz
in the primary right and you and I had
many discussions over the course of the
election cycle specifically on this
issue I think that you know you've said
you'll vote for him in 2020 I've said
that I'm highly likely to vote for him
in 2020 as well at this point what do
you make of his overall performance what
do you what are you happy with and what
are you disappointed with I'm happy with
a lot and as a conservative there's a
lot he's done that I actually like I
look at this the courts I strongly
support what he's trying to do with the
courts I look at our ally Israel
ice-truck I mean he's done things that I
don't think any Republican would have
done when it comes to the State of
Israel they've talked about it but he
actually did it I like what he's doing
with our military he's trying to
strengthen our military I like his
support for law enforcement law
enforcement isn't always right but
they've been brutalized over the last
ten years and he's making it clear that
that he as a rule stands with law
enforcement spending is completely out
of control
but you know the spending bills come to
him and unfortunately even when we had
Paul Ryan in the house I think Mitch
McConnell my opinion has been a disaster
when it comes to the budget I'm not a
great fan of his and the president has
to make a decision sign it because he's
worried about the military or veto it I
would have vetoed it but I'm not
president
so I disagree with that I think there
needs to be something done and done fast
because I think that that is a massive
issue in this country when it comes to
tariffs I don't agree with them except
in two cases China is number one China
is the enemy I don't think there's any
question about this in the South China
Sea
it's provocations in Africa where it's
building basis its provocations even in
our own hemisphere it now controls both
ends of the Panama Canal that was one of
the things that Ronald Reagan was very
concerned about the Panama Canal
it's got killer satellites up there now
we don't because Obama wouldn't fund
them China is a grave threat every bit
as dangerous as the Soviet Union and
they're getting worse and worse and
worse
so I support tires not because I believe
that somehow the
this imbalance of Tragos I don't think
people understand what that means it
doesn't count like money that flows into
this country and a very very successful
country needs raw materials and other
things from other countries so they we
import them why to satisfy my needs your
needs everybody's desires that's the way
the cookie crumbles so I'm not the
reason I support these tariffs is I want
him to do to the Chinese economy what
Reagan did to the Soviet economy now
it's gonna cost us two because as you
and I both know tariffs or attacks on us
but also it limits their ability to ship
things to us so I'm not doing it for
economic purposes because I think it's
so smart and Mexico I may be in a
minority on this to a five percent
tariff there Mexico has an obligation I
think to or the president has an
obligation to secure that border he's
done everything he can you know when you
have Democrats who are of a different
mindset who are not going to allow him
to do anything in Republicans when they
control both houses they did nothing
about it when you see that we're gonna
have 1.1 or 1.2 million illegal aliens
in this country the cost of these border
states in California's border state the
cost of these school districts law
enforcement these are these hospitals
and so forth I remember when I was in
the Reagan administration
all the way back then they were saying
we're being overwhelm a Giunta day I
mean we are really overwhelmed I think
it's important and I look at history as
you look at history and it's Trump
really doing anything truly outrageous
you know when Dwight Eisenhower was
president
he's considered sort of a moderate
Republican president so forth
he had operation I didn't name it he
named it and they rounded up 1
million illegal aliens in a period of a
year or so and it was school buses and
and and trains and trucks and move them
into the terior Mexico and so it rounded
him up he didn't care about all you're
gonna round him up he said yeah actually
we are and he put out this military
directive and that's what they did and I
compare that to a 5% tariff I think
Eisenhower would be laughing right now
so again I don't view it as wise
economically I view it as wise because
we're trying to secure the border and
he's run out
so one of the things that I've said
about President Trump is that on policy
like you I'm very happy with a lot of
his policy shortcomings I think we agree
on I have been incredibly disappointed
with spending but he never pledged he
was gonna do anything about entitlements
in fact he pledged the opposite that he
wasn't gonna do anything about
entitlements you know there are other
areas of policy like some of the other
tariffs that he's put in place that I
think are mistaken
but on regulations on judges I'm happy
there there's a second job the president
does and this is where I've been very
critical of the president for a couple
reasons one because I think the
president unfortunately in some ways is
sort of tasked with this job and to
because it actually makes a difference
to the future of conservatism and that
is the job of conveying ideas now I
think a lot of conservatives people like
you people like me who see him as a
vessel for policy we're very happily
happy with him as a vessel for policy
generally speaking the idea that he is
promoting conservative ideas I will say
on the mild end I have been disappointed
with that especially because the guy
does have a unique capacity to draw
cameras I mean the ability to draw a
spotlight for him is unbelievable and
yet the the sort of material that he
puts out into the public view is is
rarely conservative very often it's
alienating for a lot of folks and my
great fear is that we will get a lot of
good policy and then he will have
alienated so many people particularly
people who are of my generation and
younger that we're gonna be in the
wilderness for a while this is an
interesting point you raise I don't
think Donald Trump is a philosophical
conservative I think he's come to his
conservatism as a matter of practicality
and in some ways principled I and
so I don't think he's any more a
principled or philosophical conservative
than George W Bush George HW Bush I
think they've really been to in the last
a little over century I would be
Coolidge and Reagan but other than that
I can't think of any just off the top of
my head not Nixon not Ford not
eisenhower certainly not Theodore
Roosevelt and Harding and so forth so I
don't really hold that against him
in terms of him promoting that kind of
an agenda from a philosophical point of
view but I think it's kind of the not
our job and our responsibility to try
and explain that to a lot of people what
these policies are our philosophy and so
forth
I even think a lot of so-called
conservative websites and magazines have
lost their way they're fighting with
each other of what conservatism means or
they've abandoned it in some ways
because they hate Trump or they'd love
during whatever the situation is I I
feel right now the intellectual
conservative movement is very weak I
really do I think you and I and others
try to present that case but from a
broad-based perspective it's quite weak
and I think that's a problem because
some people are abandoning it I'm not
sure why 100% I'm very troubled by some
who've talked about conservatism all
these years and then all of a sudden say
well whatever what does it ever done for
us and I said let me tell you what it's
done for you nine o'clock tonight I want
you to go into one of these supermarkets
where I live they have a place called
Wegmans I don't know if they have them
in California it's as big as a football
field and I want you to walk down every
aisle ten different types of toothpaste
you can get battery-operated
toothbrushes or handheld soft medium or
and I want you to go to the meat section
and I want to see how many types of meat
the chicken section go to the wine
section wine from all over the world
just look stop telling me conservatism
doesn't work in capitalism doesn't work
we are the we have more material things
in this country and any king or queen
had two hundred years ago we got on an
airplane we fly across the country and
that's not socialism that's not big
government those are airplanes it's
technology that's creativity and we
complain whether they have peanuts or
pretzels on the plane or whether we're
sitting on the tarmac for an extra half
hour right we need that we need to put
things
perspective the things we have in this
country almost no other country has
certainly 2/3 of the world doesn't have
what do you think millions of people are
trying to claw their way into this
country because it's why because because
the middle class is is under attack
because we have systemic racism because
we're not socialists enough no it's
because of all the other reasons and so
part of it is the responsibility the
individual citizen
honestly I don't look to the President
of the United States or a senator or a
politician of a kind of tummy this is
what you need to think one of the things
that we need to continue to teach people
is think for yourselves that's a good
thing learn for you most of the stuff
I've learned about the Constitution I
sure saw it in learning in public school
I've learned it since I've been in
school and that's a good thing the
learning process goes on and on and on
but not again the first chapter liberty
and tyranny I say one of the reasons why
we don't really appreciate liberty it's
because we're surrounded by and one of
the reasons we don't appreciate what we
have is because we're surrounded by it
and so we get caught up in really stupid
arguments stupid things I'll give me an
example last week in the whole debate on
cable TV was over the word nasty when
the president said nasty referring to
comments that the princess made I've got
three days of this stuff is is this a
joke did he mean did he mean she's nasty
did he mean the stuff that she said was
nasty and I'm thinking media is nuts or
they are nuts
our focus is so off and then we had
d-day the anniversary 7,500 the other
day and I play these old clips from
World War two and you really your
patriotism is just through the roof and
you see without tremendous this
country's and the sacrifices people have
made for this country so I think it's
really on each one of us more than a
president to really explain liberty and
conservatism and constitutionalism and
this president doesn't do that anyway
most president don't do that like I said
I can think of two who basically did but
I will say this strongly in support of
the President
he doesn't preach the other two how
rotten America is you know how racist
America is the wage gaps in America I
mean like you know people can't get
health care in America so he's not one
of them and so and at his core I know he
loves his country I I do wonder still
about the the possibility that his
personality alienates a lot of people
you know it's interesting I speak to
groups of older Republicans groups of
younger Republicans wat and when I
critique the president in front of older
Republicans they start to get a little
uptight they start to get a little upset
because I'll say what I think of his
character and frankly it's not
complimentary generally and then I'll
say and I love a lot of his policy on
elbowed form and a lot of older folks
get a little upset with this and if I
say it's younger people it's the only
reason they would even consider voting
for Trump is because I'm saying to them
what I think they believe too and what
I've said is I think the reason for that
is when you're older you basically look
at politicians and maybe you have the
perspective okay well you know listen
he's a guy he does stuff I want good
what do I care honey this what he says
and when you're younger you spend an
awful lot of time considering what other
people think of you and so how you view
President Trump has now become a lens
that other people view you with so if
you're 21 you say that you like
President Trump or that you're voting
for President Trump people immediately
go to well that's because you're a
terrible person who supports everything
about him and so right is the only way
to talk to a lot of those folks is to
say okay like I like some of the stuff
he's doing but am I gonna you know
justify how he treats women that's not
it's not a thing I'm gonna do well you
know what's interesting about that and
I've thought about that some of the most
foul-mouthed comics appeal to younger
people and not older people some of the
lousy estranja
builder younger people and not the older
people one of the things I write in this
book is I address this issue of
character and in this context how the
press covered it but let me address it
in your context since Donald Trump's
been in the Oval Office I don't know of
a single hint of immoral conduct not a
hint of immoral conduct
when John Kennedy was in office it was
constant when Lyndon Johnson was office
it was constant Plus and the media
covered it up but it was all known so we
can look at the life of somebody and all
these very very imperfect people but
since he's been president terms of his
conduct in the Oval Office we haven't
had any intern problems I haven't been
any whispering none of that kind of
stuff so I want to point that out too
maybe it's the way he speaks and tweets
and people say you know I'm not used to
that and so forth and so on and people
cringe but here's another thing I'll
point out he's been called Hitler by the
media he's been called Stalin by the
media a white supremacist a race is an
anti-semite he's been called all these
things by the media he's never called
anybody any of these things now he'll
say like with Nancy Pelosi a horrible
person and Nance
I haven't agree with that person a nasty
person of this setting that bit
Oh your presidential you shouldn't act
that way but you know he didn't have a
honeymoon a hundred a honeymoon the
transition between one administration
the other it seems like the Democrats
didn't really want to transition from
one administration to the other so to me
I see this battle that's going on now is
a constitutional battle as the Democrats
wanting to remove a man who they never
wanted in office in the first place and
and and then I regard a poker they
showed look at look at my hand and this
is what we're gonna push the hall to
whether we can ride Mahler whether we
can ride Pietschmann whatever it is and
and so maybe it's me as a Philadelphia
maybe that's the instinct maybe this way
I was in I don't like that kind of stuff
so when you're trying to remove a duly
elected president and disenfranchise 63
million people the tweets are very
secondary to me I don't know how other
people feel young people feel it's like
it's it's okay all hands on deck that
doesn't mean everything that's done I
agree without you know I show too and I
explained where I agree and don't agree
but it means this is a top issue if
you're gonna remove a president or try
to remove a Prez
based on the arguments you're making
that is damaging to this country that's
damning to the Constitution so he calls
Nancy Pelosi horrible or or talks about
some of these looks because they've
talked about his looks it almost at this
point it just it just bounces off so
let's turn to the other side of the
aisle so we're approaching 2020 a lot of
speculation about who the Democratic
nominee will be or whether President
Trump wins reelection so first let me
get your odds and whether President
Trump wins re-election at this point
obviously all the smart folks including
me had Hillary Clinton winning in 2016
this what the data sort of suggested not
sort of largely almost entirely
suggested and now I'm not betting on
anything ever again I lost $10,000 in
that election so I'd be betting on
politics business if you have to if you
have to estimate the president's chances
in 2020 how would you put those first
one fairness to you even his campaign
wasn't sure I don't know and I'm not
trying to duck it's gonna be very very
tough I saw polls but it's really early
for polls but still they're taken and
people look at him in Michigan and
Wisconsin he's double digits behind
Biden and Bernie Sanders and I look at
politics almost as military operations
in terms of getting votes sneaking up
hitting them where they're not ready and
stuff like that
they weren't ready for him in Michigan
and Wisconsin they didn't campaign in
Michigan now they've got teams of people
in these heavily blue-collar union
states because they don't want to happen
what happened before they're targeting
the suburbs like they never targeted the
suburbs before but the president has a
pretty damn good record on the economy
and and on other things as well national
security that he can run on and and one
of the things he is also going for him
would be his opponents I mean let's be
on a percent of them are nuts
they're just absolute crackpots and
Bernie Sanders I mean you can only hide
I'll say from your Marxism for so long
he's got the 50-year hit he's an old red
from Brooklyn as you know we're well
familiar with who he is Joe Biden I mean
Joe Biden is the bubble man they try and
protect him as much as he can from
himself because he says dumb things
because he's not particularly bright
and in fact Obama at some point may
endorse him but even Obama won't endorse
him now
when George HW Bush was running and was
challenged in the Republican primary I
think by Pat Buchanan and so it Ronald
Reagan endorsed his vice president Obama
won't endorse his vice president well
you know we got to take notice of that
fit and look what he just did he
flip-flop on abortion no abortions a
fundamental issue okay well I want I
don't want the government to fund it and
he takes heat for for data okay I mean I
do want the government after 46 years
yeah it's it's incredible so I don't
know what to make of this election
I really don't I'm very very hopeful
Trump wins re-election because if he
doesn't it's gonna give further
motivation to our media to continue to
do what they're doing which i think is
very destructive of this republic let
alone freedom of the press
it's going to continue to motivate the
kook left in this country and they're
they're crazy agenda which would
fundamentally change the country you
know as I think about this question you
know early on in our before our country
the colonies the press they wanted to
fundamentally transform government that
is you know the monarchy they want a
representative government limited
government and so forth the progressive
movement likes government they want to
fundamentally transform man and
fundamentally transform this civil
society that's the great difference and
whether the president is making that
statement or not he's the man we have to
defend one kind of a society and the
Democrats are pushing another kind of
society and they know what they're doing
I don't mean they know the specifics of
the plan they know where they're pushing
us they don't have a plan for us to show
us the point they're never going to but
that's the direction they're pushing us
in and so I don't know who's going to
win but I'm gonna be full throated for
this president against any other
nominees I don't even see a so-called
centrist running and let me know are
there any I don't even know if there any
so-called centrist left in the
leadership of the Democrat is supposed
to be Biden but in all fairness to him
Alyssa Milano did call him on the phone
and that changes everything apparently
apparently one call from the the
star of charmed and you just shift where
you were for 15 years that issue but
don't worry he's a solid rock he's the
person you can trust in times of trouble
in this is one of the things that's been
troubling me so much about the
Democratic Party I make a distinction in
my language routinely between leftist
and liberal liberals are people I
disagree with on politics leftist are
people who want to shut down the debate
are interested in polarizing people
specifically on the basis of race for
political gain and and it seems like the
left has taken over completely the
Democratic Party is interesting I was
watching with my wife an old movie the
other night movie called born yesterday
with Judy Holliday and and Broderick
Crawford and the movie is from 1950 it's
an incredibly patriotic film in the
entire film is basically William Holden
showing Judy Holliday around the city of
Washington DC and she he brings her to
see the Constitution and Declaration of
Independence they go to the Jefferson
Memorial and he's telling her all about
the wonderful founding philosophy and I
turned to my wife and I said there's no
way this movie gets made today because
the entire narrative of left has shifted
even in my lifetime I'm old enough to
remember when the Democratic Party
actually still at least paid lip service
to the foundations of the country and
talked about how wonderful founding
philosophy was and now it seems that the
narrative is dominance in the Democratic
Party that the founding philosophy was
effectively just racism sexism bigotry
and homophobia dressed up in fancy
clothes and then sold people and that
what we really have to do is cleanse the
palate get rid of all these documents
and start fresh
obviously it scares the hell out of me
I'm seeing young people who don't know
anything about history buying into it
how do you combat all of that you know
the institution that is that there
really needs to be dealt with in one
form or another is education public
education and universities and colleges
and you and I fund them the American
people are funding our own demise
somehow people get tenure not all but
too many vast majority in our public
schools the NEA the AFT and our colleges
and universities they get tenure and
they are people who reject our founding
principles I mean I I always wonder how
many battles of the Civil War actually
taught my vote each battle is so
incredible so unique how many battles in
World War two how many battles of the
Revolutionary War do kids do they know
what Lexington and Concord is all about
these are things that would inspire
patriotism and support for the country
instead you're right the founders had no
positive characteristics they were
slaves so they must be dismissed and it
was Abraham Lincoln who did the greatest
job of explaining the founding and the
founders and did more for African
American slaves in this country than any
left-wing professor or any leftist on TV
that you can imagine he led the civil
war and what Lincoln said in 1858 and
Beyond and he loved the founders he said
those men wrote the Declaration of
Independence there's not a word about
slavery and the Declaration of
Independence every individual is created
by God unattainable rights he said so
the men those men knew that slavery was
wrong but they also could not create a
country because certain states like
Georgia and South Carolina weren't going
to go for it but they knew that their
children and their grandchildren would
have to address this that's why they
wrote the Declaration of Independence
the way that they did and he says it's
their writing their Constitution that
will enable us to smite this because
otherwise we would have had a country
and you still would have had states or
colonies with slavery and states and
colonies without it but history is not
taught it certainly wasn't in when I was
in high school I still got the same
pablum the same left-wing agenda they
have managed the progressive movement to
really control ideologically virtually
every instrumentality of our culture
right now that's why we have these
culture wars whether it's the courts
whether it's whether it's the
bureaucracy whether it's education
whether it's the media we always start
with the progressive foundation and
we're always on defense
but trying to respond to these things
we've got to do something about colleges
and universities and I think we the
people need to start speaking with our
wallets and states need to start
withholding funds you're gonna be
subsidized well don't be subsidized so
much
make sure when you send your kid to
college if you're involved in that
decision that you don't send them to an
indoctrination mill you know just
because it's an Ivy League school
doesn't mean they have to go there
there's other schools out there where
they'll get me more traditional
education and so on but this is
something I've been thinking a lot about
maybe one day I'll write about and give
it more focused thought but it is a huge
huge problem I mean so you spent an
entire lifetime basic trying to educate
people about all of this stuff you've
written as bevy of philosophically
linked books and and going all the way
back through American history so if you
had to kind of give a beginner's reading
list for people you're the history
professor now so well what's the well
what are the books that you would
recommend aside from your own to young
students who are maybe interested in
this stuff kids who are 10 11 12 years
olds who are first getting introduced to
American history well I would do it the
way I did it which is there wasn't one
book or one author if I would read a
book and they would refer to the Stamp
Act or something like that I go read the
Stamp Act and we have but it's right
over our finger but I go to the avalon
project and look at original documents
they're out there and I would do those
sorts of things so there's certain
professors I like certain books I like
but what I would encourage people to do
is go do it yourself it's actually
entertaining it's actually interesting
so if you want to learn about the press
you could take a book like mine over 400
endnotes in there the reason I do that
just so you can look at the end notes
and go look yourself
there were historians at the time Ramzi
is an example most people have never
heard of before he was a real time
historian about the Revolutionary War
which is why the later progressive
historians attack him because they want
to change the history of America from a
battle over government to a battle
between classes which is what they do so
I would suggest that people go look at
the original document you don't need
people to explain the Declaration of
Independence to read it you don't need
people well you might help you with the
Constitution but first read it I in many
ways I don't even care what the Supreme
Court says I read the cases like you do
because we need to explain them but
those are lawyers justices they have
they make
they have an effect but that's their
opinion on what the Constitution says I
want to read the Constitution of why it
says what it says look at the history
English common law other things
Montesquieu and separation of powers
Locke when it comes to the Declaration
of Independence go back and read those
people you'll be a lot smarter and I
think a lot more fulfilled so I'm gonna
ask you a tough question that I often
get when I'm speaking on college
campuses so the question that I get
pretty frequently as a follow up to the
kind of what books do you recommend or
is there anybody on the left that you
read is there are there any liberals
that you think it's it's worth reading
or that you enjoy or think are
interesting out there not really I mean
some of them are very smart
but I feel like I'm bombarded with this
every day and if I'm going to read a
leftist I'll read an old leftist I'll
read a John Dewey or a while or these
guys that push the progressive movement
or Wilson these other guys they are the
founding fathers of the modern day
Democrat Party they are the founding
fathers of the progressive movement so
if you really want to understand what
Obama is saying or what their progeny
are saying read them and there's a lot
to read and they're not the only ones
but they're the ones that provided the
the so-called intellectual basis for
modern-day progressives or even go back
further read Marx and Engels and Hegel
and Rousseau and these guys because
that's what Bernie Sanders read I'm
dying to have Bernie Sanders on one of
my programs I'm sure you are too
he will not come on any of my programs
because I want to talk to him about
marks and angles and Hegel and Rousseau
and and and doing all these other guys
who people who he embraces rather than
these shows he goes on a whole careful
you do a great things health care for
all people and in these superficial
interviews where he's just saying you
have a right to this you're let's talk
about this what do you mean by that
you go I would love to do it but the
only way I'm able to do is cuz I read
those things not people who've read
those things telling me what those
people said just read those people it's
out there
so many people who listen to you may not
know kind of how you got into the
commentary business in the first place
like I've been following
since I was old enough to listen to talk
radio but for a lot of people who have
only heard of you that way how did you
even get into doing this sort of thing
well starting in a log cabin no no
really
well I when I was a kid I would listen
to talk radio and listen to guys like
Bob gran in New York and others and I
was mesmerized by it and I'd listened to
it to midnight 2:00 in the morning I
actually listened to hosts had anyone
agree with I just thought that whole
format was fascinating and then when I
was about 16 years old I contacted our
local radio station was WCAU and ah WP
HT it's a big 50,000 watt station and I
asked her if I could do a show and of
course they blew me off but then they
did bring me in said just one Sunday and
I did it that was that and I thought
that was fine and went on with my legal
career and then you know I heard Rush
and I heard
Sean I used to listen to other talk
radio throughout even when I was writing
briefs and doing other things and so
forth
and kind of hooked up with rusher he
hooked up with me I don't really exactly
remember how that happened but I would
provide him with legal information
constitutional information then he dub
me F Lee Levin his legal director and
then Sean same thing and then they would
have me sit in for them now and then and
then WABC asked me if I would do a
Sunday show for nothing I said okay I'll
do it it's pretty cool to test down on
WABC in New York and that's what I did
and after about 14 months of that they
asked me to do a show which is how I got
here so what's your conservative origin
story I mean how did you get
conservative in the first place because
you're in a talk radio from when you
were 16 but have you always held these
politics I've always held these views
and I've wondered because my parents
always wanted and by the way they were
always conservatives but I don't mean in
terms of philosophical conservatives and
1964 they voted for Goldwater and
they're Jewish
they were conservatives and I asked my
dad back then you voted for Goldwater
why did you vote for gold he said I knew
the BS they were saying how cold water
was wrong and I
to think about that said I have that
genes I don't like people pushing me
around I don't like bullies and I don't
like authoritarians and that's what the
left is all about bullies and
authoritarians so I don't like being
pushed around whether it's a regulation
a tax a government talking down to me a
government telling me I can't think for
myself and by the way I think this is
how we appeal the younger and younger
people because I don't think they like
it either so it's not so much
anti-authoritarian as anti-authority
it's anti-authoritarianism and so in
other words what I'm saying is autocracy
is a bad thing
whether it's practice one-on-one in the
playground or whether it's practice by
government and that's what I think
that's what I reject that's why I
started to say what I'd like Liberty I
like individualism I like to be left
alone I like to kind of do what I want
to do and if that's the way you think
then big government and the left is not
your answer okay so in a second I want
to ask you one final question I wanna
ask you if your top five presidents and
your bottom five presidents cuz it's
kind of a fun thought experiment but if
you want to hear mark Levins answer you
have to be a daily wire subscriber to
subscribe head on over to daily wire
comm click subscribe you can hear the
end of our conversation over there well
thank you so much for stopping by it's
been a blast he's great to see you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jessa
alvera title graphics by Cynthia Angulo
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]